but only you the american people in five
days can stop this and shock the world
again
and tonight more and more americans are
backing the president's pro-growth
pro-freedom agenda look at this little
wayne has now come forward praising the
president
for his work with criminal justice
reform his ongoing efforts to increase
opportunities in the african-american
community here with reaction
uh co-author of the new book the cost
trump
china and american revival the host of
mornings with maria
on the fox business network we see her
every weekend here on the fox news
channel maria baratoromo
congrats on the book 33.1
thank you so much 33 33.1
you know markets as well as anybody i
know would you like to explain
yeah sean thank you so much things are
getting better for sure
that gdp number better than expected a
baffle number at 33.1 percent annually
but when you dig deeper into this number
it really is stunning what's going on
automobile production was up almost 1200
percent
you just mentioned business equipment
spending 70 percent higher
the consumer is holding up incredibly
well here we are seeing a rebound and we
are going to see continued growth
in the fourth quarter and into 2021.
what's really stunning sean is the how
well the consumer is handling
uh this pandemic and how he or she is
holding up so well
even in the face of a lack of any more
stimulus
this morning i spoke with larry kudlow
and he said an interesting thing
happened today
uh nancy pelosi sent secretary mnuchin a
letter
about these stimulus negotiations but
somehow
politico got a hand of that got a hold
of that letter before it actually
reached steven mnuchin
it was leaked to politico before it even
got to the treasury secretary
larry kudlow said we are out this is
game over
she is stringing us along and as you see
from these numbers it's okay so far we
are going to need some stimulus at some
point
but right now the economy is certainly
showing that rebound in a v-shaped
recovery and it's looking good sean
you know nobody ever talks about joe and
barack's agenda number one they didn't
do criminal justice reform police reform
opportunity zones they never had a
platinum plan nor did they ever set
record low unemployment for
african-americans hispanic americans
asian americans women in the workforce
youth unemployment and african-american
youth unemployment
donald trump did that so i look at their
record
now correct me if i'm wrong because if
memory serves me well
biden and obama added 13 million more
americans to food stamps 8 million more
in poverty
the lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s the worst recovery since
the 40s
the lowest homeownership rate in 51
years and accumulated more debt than all
presidents before them right or wrong
it was right that's right it was the
slowest recovery on record
one thing that this administration has
done is really reach out to create a
bigger tent this morning on mornings
with maria i had an exclusive with ice
cube
and cube was telling me how he worked
with the administration
to actually come up with new ideas to
reach out to the black community
reach out to hispanics that platinum
plan is really resonating and one
issue there is the fact that wages
started to rise before covert showed up
remember back in february and january of
this year we had an unemployment rate of
three and a half percent
the lowest on record every income level
felt that tax
cut plan and every income level so wages
going up but importantly the lowest
of the income earners were actually
seeing their wages go up even higher
than the top earners that was really
incredible
and for the first time in decades we
actually saw the beginning
of the income inequality story beginning
to narrow
the black community is now seeing this
and
understanding that president trump has
actually made an impact on their lives
that's why there are some expectations
that the black vote is going to come out
for president trump
to the tune of 20 to 30 percent sean
that is a huge number i don't think
we've ever seen anything like
this okay you look at all the blue
cities and all the blue states run by
liberal democrats for decades look at
chicago
biden obama president vice president
eight years
4 000 homicides 20 000 shootings
they barely mention it okay you got all
of these cities
how would you grade them with law and
order
and safety and security i'd give them an
f how would you grade them with
education
i'd give them an f how did obamacare
work out
millions lost doctors millions lost
plans and we all paid about 200 percent
more
so why would people put their faith hope
and trust
when they don't even do the fundamentals
of keeping people safe and educating our
kids
uh well at all why give them more
responsibility
right well exactly and the truth is is
economic security equals
national security that's why the economy
is so critical here
ensuring that all income levels are
getting what they need in terms of
opportunities to work and make as much
money as they can
that creates safety that it creates law
and order
so you really need to start with the
economy and start with policies that
actually
reach all income levels that's what this
administration has done
look the open borders policy the other
policies in a lot of these democratic
cities have clearly failed look at nancy
pelosi's district in san francisco
homelessness drugs on the street the
place is a wreck unfortunately i was
there earlier this year and it's a sad
state of affairs
you look at different democrat-run
states and clearly
the policies are not working you need a
policy that
is inclusive and a policy that actually
creates
economic security which leads to safety
and national security
and then we got candidate doom and gloom
uh well somebody tell joe
i'm sure he gets his oatmeal and his
applesauce every day
in between spoonfuls just tell them that
the vaccine is on the horizon
therapeutics are working and the economy
has come back in spite of his doom and
gloom
maria congrats on the book